which shapes are symmetrical
to answer this we need to know what it
means for a shape to be
symmetrical
a shape is symmetrical if it has at
least one line
of symmetry a line of symmetry
and now that answer is only helpful
if we know what a line of symmetry is so
let's talk about it
a line of symmetry is a line where we
can fold the image and have both halves
match exactly
let's look at an example
let's draw let's say you draw a circle
and then we can put a line on that
circle let's draw a line maybe somewhere
like this
this line is a line of symmetry if we
can take one side of the line
and fold it onto the other and have them
match exactly
so let's take one side doesn't matter
which one let's say the top
the top side
and if we were going to fold this top
side down onto the bottom would it match
exactly what is shown under here let's
see it would probably look something
like
this
and does that match exactly no
definitely not so this is not
a line of symmetry
let's try another line
maybe if we drew a line and we'll try to
get as close down the center as we can
here
like this
try to be as close to the center as
possible and here if we took one side
again it doesn't matter which side let's
say over here let's say the left side
and we folded this left side on to the
right side
would it match exactly and if our line
truly was in the center of the circle
then yes it would
which means that this line is a line of
symmetry
and because we can draw this line of
symmetry on our circle it means that our
circle is symmetrical
shapes are symmetrical if they have at
least one line of symmetry
and circles have many many many lines of
symmetry there was many places we could
have drawn a line and folded it so that
it worked so the two halves matched
exactly
but here's one and as soon as we find
one we know we have a symmetrical shape
so let's go back to the shapes we were
given we can start with the triangle
if we draw a line maybe a vertical line
let's try to draw it as close to the
middle as possible something like this
and we fold let's take one side if we
fold this side over these two lines
might match up nicely
but this line here is going to create
something more like this
which does not match which is what's
shown over here so that's not a line of
symmetry and anywhere else vertical same
thing we're not going to have it lined
up
so let's try maybe a horizontal line is
there anywhere horizontally we could
draw a line and again i think we're
going to see the same thing that the top
and the bottom of the line are not going
to match up exactly
so maybe one last thing we could try is
a diagonal line something like this
maybe this could be our line of symmetry
if we fold this bottom side this might
line up pretty nice here
and then this side
is going to do something like this
so it's close it's the closest we've
gotten but still does not match exactly
for it to be a line of symmetry it needs
to match exactly
so we weren't able to find a way to draw
a vertical line or a horizontal line or
even the diagonal line
so this shape has no lines of symmetry
so we can say it is not symmetrical
moving on to the rectangle
let's try here again
this time i will try a horizontal line
we can draw one
right here
and if that line truly is in the middle
which is what i've tried for
then this side should match up nicely to
this one
across the top should match across the
bottom
and these sides if i was right at the
halfway point should fold over each
other also
so it has a line of symmetry so it is
symmetrical it has more than one line of
symmetry it has another one
in the middle right here
but once we found one we know that it's
symmetrical
and finally let's look we have a
pentagon
here again trying a line in the middle
in some way is usually a good place to
start
we can try to draw a line right if this
is right down the center
here
then if we folded this side
should line up nicely to this side
this side and this side would overlap
and these two would match exactly
so again
has one line of symmetry so it is
symmetrical and just like the rectangle
this one had quite a few lines of
symmetry here's another line of symmetry
here's another line of symmetry
here's one more line of symmetry
and so it has quite a few it has it
looks like one two three four lines of
symmetry but as long as it has one it is
symmetrical so of the shapes we were
given the rectangle and the pentagon
were symmetrical